welcome back to new rockstars I'm Aaron
Voss and Star Wars Episode nine the rise
of Skywalker
made a bold move with a character of
Leia bringing back the late Carrie
Fisher's character with archived footage
to play a far more active role in the
story than other recreated live-action
characters ever do at least way more
active than when they rotoscoped the
late Yoda on a baby
the original plan for this new trilogy
was for the force awakens to be Han
story the last Jedi to be Luke's story
and the rise of Skywalker to be Leia
story now unfortunately Carrie Fisher's
passing in late 2016
midway through filming the last Jedi
seemed to alter that plan but
surprisingly director JJ Abrams appears
to have reverted to that plan for the
final film because this story is very
much Leia's story how did he pull that
off and how is the technology used
different from the other times they've
tried this in Star Wars films and more
importantly why was it so important to
bring Leia back like what key role does
she play in this film how did they
revise her backstory and what exactly
happened Stuart in the rise of Skywalker
because I'll admit it did take me a
couple viewings to sort it out further
warning obviously okay first off how did
they bring Leia back while promoting the
film Abrams promised that they would not
be using VFX technology to digitally
reconstruct Leia the way road 1
reconstructed young Leia and the late
Peter Cushing's grand moff tarkin
that process involved stand-in
look-alikes facial reassembly and
animators awkwardly trying to puppet
digital mouths to speak new dialogue by
comparison the rise of Skywalker sticks
exclusively to archived footage and
dialogue of Carrie Fisher from the force
awakens in the last Jedi using a process
called rotoscoping to clip out Fisher's
whole face from that footage and
superimposing it on a stand and actor in
these scenes and then adjusting for
color in lighting so that they match
it's kind of a more old-school process
like George Lucas used rotoscoping to
make the lightsaber effect in the
original Star Wars and it's more
respectful arguably since you're
preserving the actors performance
instead of doing a kind of digital
plastic surgery to turn their face into
a weird mask now the downsides are that
you could say maybe the edges of the
clipped out face can seem a bit blurry
and in this movie's case abrams was
limited to the exact dialogue and
reaction shots that they had on file
from Fisher and they had to write all of
her scenes around those existing clips
like in this movie Leia says the line
never underestimate a Troy which was
originally from a deleted clip from the
force awakens a scene in which Laius
told about Poe crash-landed on jakku and
bb-8 having gone missing but now the
line is repurposed to refer to that
pesky training droid now not all the
repurposed dialog transitions are as
smooth but I would argue the process was
worth it for the way abrams updates
Laius backstory one of the criticisms of
the last Jedi concerned Leia's space
glide after her apparent death this is
definitely one of the more supernatural
applications of the force that we've
ever seen made more confusing by the
fact that the canonical films had never
firmly established Leia as a Jedi like
the Empire Strikes Back and Return of
the Jedi hint at her force sensitivity
and legends stories followed her future
Jedi training some of which has been
brought over into her canonical post
Empire history according to Lucasfilm
but the force awakens characterized her
as a military general not someone who
has dedicated years and years and years
to the ways of the Jedi a monkish
dedication that would probably be
required to pull off that kind of move
but the rise of skywalker
addresses this head-on early in the film
rey participates in some intense
training overseen by her new master leia
rey later revisits luke's island and
discovers a lightsaber owned by leia a
flashback shows Luke training leia in
some badass lightsaber combat and they
use more archived footage of Mark
Hamill's and Carrie Fisher's younger
appearances really of all the Star Wars
films the rise of Skywalker has the most
in common with Return of the Jedi
Palpatine emerging from the shadows to
offer a hero a deal with the devil the
character we thought was a villain
actually rediscovering his soul in
Redemption Lando back in a falcon where
he belongs
but more than anything it shows us a
Return of the Jedi and now that Jedi
includes Leia her voice joins a
cacophony of all the other Jedi who
speak down to Rey in her darkest moment
but this disembodied voice leads us to
the question what exactly happened to
Leia like how did she die
but before he continued this video was
sponsored by audible in their unmatched
selection of audio books and other audio
products this holiday season he might
have gotten some real stinker gifts
thanks a lot Nana give yourself a gift
that you'll love the gift of audible
membership membership includes one free
audio book a month in to audible
originals unlike a streaming a rental
service with audible you
all your books and you get to keep them
even if you cancel I got dune by Frank
Herbert's classic so that I could brush
up on my sand worm knowledge ahead of
the 2020 film version by Din evil noob
they got tons of dune titles as well as
Star Wars and Game of Thrones pretty
much a sci-fi and fantasy audio paradise
members stay motivated and inspired with
unlimited access to exclusive guided
fitness and meditation programs perfect
for helping you stick with those New
Year's resolutions start listening with
a 30 day audible trial choose one
audiobook in two audible originals
absolutely free visit audible.com slash
new rock stars or text new rock stars to
500 500 again that's audible.com slash
new rock stars or text new rock stars -
500 500 for one audiobook and two
audible originals absolutely free so
when kylo confronts rey on the ruins of
the second death star back on the rebel
base leia doubles over in pain and lies
down Maz Kanata says Leia knows what
must be done to reach her son now will
take all the strength she has left back
in the duel kylo rears back to deliver
his death blow but his mother's voice
rings out man kylo stops and turns
sensing her just as he felt in their
moment of connection in the last Jedi
kylo drops his lightsaber and in this
second of hesitation Rey catches the
lightsaber and uses kylos lightsaber to
stab him as I'm sure she has wanted to
do every second since watching kylo
shove this same blade through Han Solo
the moment ray gets her revenge she then
feels a wash of guilt because she senses
Leia - and she gasps and Rey realizes
she made a huge mistake
she didn't defeat kylo Ren she exploited
a reunion between mother and son
but Leia knew the only way to save Rey
was to use all of her strength to
connect with her son Ray's stabbing kylo
Ren with this red blade symbolically
killed his kylo Ren identity and by
using empathy and forced healing to
bring him back she frees him to return
to his bend solo identity Leia
essentially willed her spirit into her
son sacrificing herself so that her son
could feel loved once more and in her
final breaths Leia drops the rebel
medallion that she gave to Han in the
first film r2d2 beeps sadly the princess
who once entrusted everything to
destroyed now
on now at this point of the film Leia's
spirit is now linked with Ben it's how
Ben is now able to see a projection of
his father Han and Chuck his red
lightsaber into the sea the third act of
the film is all about Ben proving his
change of conscience by killing the
Knights of Ren joining Ray's side and
transferring his life force into her to
return the favor and bring her back in
the moment Ben dies he fades just as
other Jedi have done upon their deaths
simultaneously Leia's body fades as well
so was she not actually dead under that
sheet Maz Kanata was like ooh I'm glad I
didn't bury her
no no Laius corporeal body was deceased
but her spirit now lived on with Ben for
these final moments and once son Jedi
passes on so does mom a Jedi what did
you think of Leia's portrayal in the
rise of Skywalker was her role in her
parents respectful to Carrie Fisher's
memory comment down below with your
thoughts and be sure to check out my
other videos on the rise of Skywalker
like how Palpatine resurrected and what
his plan was the deeper meaning of the
final scene and of course all the Easter
eggs that you might have missed in this
film follow me on instagram and twitter
at EI vas and subscribed a new rock
starts to break down so they have
everything you love thanks for joining
me bye
[Music]